foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to a new episode of RT
Essentials I'm Perry nemeroff on today's
show we're taking you all the way down
the street to Hollywood that's right
these are our favorite movies that are
censored around feature or directly
about the art or business of making
movies here in Hollywood this list spans
from the 1950s all the way up to today
and includes people who like to sing in
the rain a few Tinseltown related
murders and of course Nicholas Cage so
hop on our double decker tour bus yes
that is a thing around here and let's go
on a virtual ride through the best
movies about Hollywood and action
adaptation
there's a bump I'm starting to sweat and
stop sweating I've got to stop sweating
can't you see it dripping down my
forehead
oh she looked at my hairline she thinks
I'm bald do you think you're great oh
wow thanks that's that's nice to hear
kicking off this list is 2002's
adaptation this film was directed by
Spike Jones who had previously helmed
another Hollywood type
1999's Being John Malkovich this one
Stars Nicholas Cage as real life La
screenwriter Charlie Kaufman who runs
into writer's block as he tries to adapt
the Susan Orlean novel The Orchard Thief
as his life becomes more intertwined
with Orleans book with Meryl Streep
playing the author things go from
pathetic to very bizarre for Charlie the
film was written by the real Charlie
Kaufman who based the script on his
struggles to adapt the same book while
suffering from writer's block however
many story elements and characters are
exaggerated or completely made up
including the presence of a twin brother
Donald also played by Nick Cage
there you go the Killer's a literature
professor he cuts off little chunks from
his victims bodies until they die
he calls himself the deconstructionist
that's kind of good I like that see I
was kidding Donald
oh okay sorry speaking of Charlie it was
actually Tom Hanks who was originally
close to playing the role before cage
ended up getting it and cage took a 5
million dollar salary which is a bit on
the low side and also wore a fat suit
during filming meanwhile Streep was
reportedly very interested in the role
of Susan Orlean and also took a salary
cut to help with the film's budget when
it comes to John larochet the actual
Orchid Thief Joaquin Phoenix auditioned
and John Turturro was approached for the
role which eventually went to Chris
Cooper and what did he do with it he won
an Oscar for best supporting actor and
that's what he did adaptation picked up
a ton of awards on the festival circuit
and along with Cooper's win it was also
nominated for three other Oscars
including cages second streets 13th and
one ironically for best adapted
screenplay
Sunset Boulevard you see the body of a
young man was found floating in the pool
of her mansion
with two shots in his back and one in
his stomach nobody important really
just a movie writer with a couple of B
pictures to his credit
the poor dope
he always wanted a pool
cruising with the top down to the next
spot on this list is 1950s Sunset
Boulevard directed and co-written by the
oscar-winning Billy Wilder this film
stars William Holden as Joe Gillis A
struggling screenwriter and Gloria
Swanson as Norma Desmond an aging silent
film Queen who refuses to accept that
her stardom has ended Norma hires Joe to
help with her comeback but they soon
develop in dangerous relationship that
becomes one of Madness and violence the
film was named after a major street that
runs through Hollywood and I very much
suggest staying off of it during rush
hour which has been associated with the
film industry since 1911 when the town's
first film studio Nestor opened there
let's get a good look at you
no there's no what this one
normative
Norma Desmond well I thought she was
dead how nice to see you welcome home Mr
you remember me
for filming Wilder used authentic
locations like a mansion on Sunset and
for Joe's Apartment a real apartment
Block in central Hollywood that was
often populated by struggling writers
the character of Norma resembled a
number of real-life silent film stars
who had faded out Wilder wanted May West
for the role to Star alongside Marlon
Brando but neither of them were
interested the part eventually went to
Swanson one of the most celebrated
silent error actresses who unlike her
character made a smooth transition to
the talkies although she hadn't appeared
in a film in nearly a decade at that
point Sunset Boulevard is often ranked
amongst the greatest movies of all time
and earns 11 Oscar nominations including
all four acting categories and it won
three for best writing best art
Direction and best music and the critics
consensus calls this one arguably the
greatest movie about Hollywood boom mic
drop Mulholland Drive
I'm sorry that was a highly recognition
considered one of the finest espressos
in the world what is going on here there
is no way that girl is in my mind
foreign
into the next spot on this list is
2001's Mulholland Drive this
psychological Thriller was written and
directed by David Lynch of Twin Peaks
Fame of course and is set in a dream
like Los Angeles AKA there's no traffic
or smog it centers around Laura
herring's Rita who after a car accident
on the windy Mulholland Drive develops
Amnesia she's taken in by a perky
Hollywood hopeful named Betty played by
Naomi Watts and together they try and
search for Rita's true identity the
movie also follows other vignettes and
characters including a young Hollywood
film director played by Justin Thoreau
who's facing major problems in both his
personal and his professional life the
film's title is a reference to iconic
Hollywood culture Lynch lives near the
actual Mulholland Drive and is said he
could feel the history of Hollywood in
that road I'm sorry it happens sometimes
no come on no she said it was someone
else I was in trouble stop it Louise I'm
taking you home
come on
good night Betty good night
good night
wow
Mulholland Drive was originally
conceived as a TV pilot and when it was
shot on location in Los Angeles in the
fall of 1999 Lynch left it open-ended it
wasn't until TV execs passed on that
that he went back and added an ending
and made it a feature film along with
being named after a real Hollywood Road
the film also references a real
Hollywood Road Rage incident where the
rose character smashes a windshield with
a golf club just like Jack Nicholson did
infamously in 1994. Lynch was nominated
for a Best Director Oscar for his work
on the film which has also been credited
as boosting the profile of Naomi Watts
Singing in the Rain just because you're
a big movie star wild party swimming
pools you expect every girl to find a
dead fan at your feet well don't you
touch me fear not sweet lady I will not
molest you I am but a humble Jester and
you you are too far above me farewell
little Barrymore I must tell myself from
your side
Making a Splash is the next film on this
list is 1952's singing in the rain this
classic was directed and choreographed
by Gene Kelly and Stanley donnen and
also Stars Kelly alongside Donald
O'Connor Debbie Reynolds and Gene Hagan
the film gives a lighthearted depiction
of the turmoil that the movie industry
went through in the late 1920s making
the transition from Silent to sound and
also covers the performers who were
caught in the middle of all of it the
idea for Singing in the Rain was based
on a back catalog of songs that already
existed writers Betty Compton and Adolf
green were brought in to build a story
in a script around them and since most
of the songs were written during the
time when silent films were fading out
that's where the story was set okay
again quiet
foreign
we're missing every other word you've
got to talk into the mic well I kid
man the rain wasn't a huge hit initially
but it's since been given Legend status
by contemporary critics who often
consider it one of the best films ever
made which is why it's so cool that
Debbie Reynolds acquired most of the
costumes from the movie for her massive
collection of Hollywood memorabilia most
of which was sold at auction in 2011.
the film was nominated for an Oscar for
best score with Gene Hagan also getting
a non for best supporting actress Donald
O'Connor picked up a Golden Globe for
his performance while Condon and green
won the writer's Guild award for their
screenplay and top critic Ben Flanagan
from Little White Lies called this one
effervescent life-affirming Cinema an
antidote to any ailment illness or woes
about the state of Hollywood
la la lands and you're gonna play the
set list happy too even though I don't
think anyone cares what I play but yeah
well if by anyone you mean anyone other
than me that would be correct I care and
I don't want to hear the free jazz right
okay although I I thought in this town
it worked on a sort of one for you one
for me type system
how about two for you one for me
how about all for you and none for me
that's perfect yes great okay next on
our list of the best movies about
Hollywood is 2016's La La Land This film
was written and directed by Damien
chazelle and stars Ryan Gosling as
Sebastian a struggling jazz pianist and
Emma Stone as Mia an aspiring actress
the two Central characters meet in Los
Angeles and are drawn together by their
common desire to do what they love but
they're eventually faced with difficult
decisions about their relationships as
success continues to mount Giselle wrote
the screenplay after moving to Los
Angeles in 2010 as a salute to creative
people who chase their dreams in La the
idea was to ground the classic musical
in real life where things don't always
work out but he couldn't find a studio
willing to finance the production until
after the success of his 2014 film
Whiplash Miles Teller and Emma Watson
were originally slated to star in this
one but they both dropped out to pave
the way for Gosling and Stone
maybe I'm one of those people that has
always wanted to do it
but it's like a pipe dream
for me you know and then you you said it
you you change your dreams and then you
grow up maybe I'm one of those people
and I'm not supposed to and I can go
back to school
and I can find something else that I'm
supposed to do because I left
to do that and it's been six years and I
don't want to do it anymore
ironically Watson reportedly turned down
the role of Mia to appear in Beauty and
the Beast while Ryan Gosling turned down
the role of the beast in that film to
appear in this one you gotta love
Hollywood filming took place in August
and September of 2015 in more than 60
locations both in and around Los Angeles
that includes Angels Flight trolley
downtown houses in the Hollywood Hills
the Warner Brothers lot and right smack
dab in the middle of the 105 freeway
which I'm sure caused zero traffic
issues La La Land grows 448 million
dollars at the worldwide box office and
was nominated for 14 Academy Awards and
won six including best actors for stone
and best director for chazelle making
him the youngest winner in this category
at the time at just 32 years old top
credit K Austin Collins from the ringers
said as an attempt to pay homage to a
Vanishing World La La Land is as dutiful
as it is endearing Ed Wood when is your
next picture coming out
I have no next picture
you gotta be joking a great star like
you you must have dozens of them lined
up back in the old days yes
no no one gives to go to bed
but you're a big star
no more I haven't worked in four years
this business is Town it chews you up
then spits you out
just the next Bogeyman
next up is the biographical dramedy from
1994 Ed Wood this film was directed and
produced by Tim Burton and stars Johnny
Depp as cult filmmaker Ed Wood focusing
on the period of wood's life when he
made his most well-known movies in the
film wood has become a Hollywood Outcast
due to his eccentric habits and odd
Productions but with the help of the
formerly famous Bella Lugosi played here
by Martin Landau at a devoted cast and
crew they managed to produce a strangely
endearing batch of low budget movies the
idea for Ed Wood came from writers Scott
Alexander and Larry karazewski who were
looking to avoid being only known for
family films after doing 1990s Problem
Child and its sequel Georgie what
happened I thought glitter Glenda was
opening this week where's the ads
where's the ads the ads are in Alabama
Indiana Missouri yo schmuck they ain't
gonna play in LA why not nobody wants to
see this piece of sh hey you can't talk
that way about my movie you're moving I
wish it was your movie I wish I'd blown
every dime I ever made making it stick
bomb and if I ever see you again I'll
tell you
[Music]
hello
Georgie
it wasn't until original director
Michael Lehman had scheduling issues
with the movie Airheads that Tim Burton
stepped into the job and while Burton
originally developed the film for
Columbia Pictures they lost interest
after the director insisted on shooting
the film in black and white opening the
door for Disney's Touchstone pictures
filming lasted 72 days in the late
summer and early fall of 1993 at various
locations around Hollywood and while the
black and white look may have
contributed to a poor box office
performance for Ed Wood fans and critics
alike loved it the film won two academy
awards for best supporting actor for
Martin Landau and best makeup and has
since worked its way up to cult classic
status
LA Confidential which is not my favorite
perfume not by a long shot
sometimes as we watched she'd clutch my
arm on my hand
forgetting she was my employer
just becoming a fan excited about that
actress up there on the screen
's LA Confidential
crime drama was directed produced and
co-written by Curtis Hansen and is based
on James elroy's novel of the same name
it tells the story of a group of LAPD
officers in 1953 exploring the
intersection of police corruption and
Hollywood celebrity as they all tackle
an unsolved murder at a downtown coffee
shop director Hansen and screenwriter
Brian helgeland worked on the script
together for two years with Hanson
turning down several jobs in that period
of time the project was pitched to
television twice and even had a
pilot-produced starring Kiefer
Sutherland but it was never picked up
when casting started for the film
version the role of Bud white was
offered to Michael Madsen before
eventually going to Russell Crowe who
actually turns it down first because he
didn't believe he could pull off such a
tough character how's it going to look
in your report it'll look like justice
that's what the man got
Justice you don't know the meaning of
the word you ignorant bastard
yeah
well you think it means getting your
picture in the paper why don't you go
after criminals for a change instead of
cops Stenson got what he deserved and so
will you Crow of course did take the
role and would ultimately go on to base
his performance on that of Sterling
Hayden from Stanley Kubrick's movie The
Killing LA Confidential was shot at 45
different locations around Los Angeles
including several famous Hollywood
landmarks appropriate to the 1950s like
the Formosa Cafe in West Hollywood the
Frolic room on Hollywood Boulevard and
an outdoor shopping mall called The
Crossroads of the world the film ended
up being a big hit with fans and critics
along with a strong performance at the
box office it was also nominated for
nine Oscars including best picture and
it won two for best adapted screenplay
and best supporting actress for Kim
Basinger's work in the film plus it was
voted the best film set in Los Angeles
in the last 25 years by a group of Los
Angeles Times writers and editors in
2008 which really is the kind of
acknowledgment that fits nicely into
this list right here once upon a time in
Hollywood put her there oh that was it
that was absolutely fantastic I loved it
and your idea about throwing the little
girl on the ground that just wasn't like
a charm you said Shakespeare still
that's right that was and that's what I
mean by scare me yeah evil Hamlet scares
people all right telling a tale is the
next spot on this list is 2019's Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood the film was
written and directed by Quentin
Tarantino and is set in 1969 Los Angeles
using multiple storylines to pay tribute
to the final moments of Hollywood's
Golden Age Leonardo DiCaprio stars as
aging actor Rick Dalton who gained Fame
and Fortune from a 1950s TV Western but
is now struggling to find meaningful
work in Hollywood and Dalton who spends
most of his time hanging out with his
longtime stunt double Cliff Booth played
by Brad Pitt just so happens to live
next door to filmmaker Roman Polansky
and actress Sharon Tate Margot Robbie
who plays Tate in the film actually wore
some of the late actresses real jewelry
which was provided by Tate's sister
[Applause]
ladies
[Music]
I'm one step closer and I will knock his
teeth out and along with Polanski and
Tate other historical characters
featured in the movie include Steve
McQueen Bruce Lee Mama Cass and also
members of the Manson family Tarantino
was first inspired to make this one
years earlier while filming Death Proof
with Kurt Russell who had been working
with the same stunt double for years
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood was shot
in and around Los Angeles from June to
November in 2018 and Tarantino kept the
only copy of the third Act of the
screenplay it is safe during that time
to prevent it from being prematurely
leaked which in this business is a very
smart move the film received 10 Academy
Award nominations including best picture
with Brad Pitt winning for best
supporting actor and top critic Wendy
eyed from The Observer UK said this is a
film set in a stunningly evoked
Hollywood past it can also be read as a
commentary on Hollywood present hail
Caesar what you think if there wasn't a
good reliable man I wouldn't have
grabbed him what about on Sesame he is
the father isn't he yeah yeah the
marriage doesn't have to last forever
but at the end of having a child without
a father would present a public
relations problem for the studio The
Aquatic pictures do very nicely for us
so you go and strap on a fish and
Mariani sayslin calling for the next
spot on this list is 2016's hail Caesar
this film was written produced edited
and directed by the brothers Joel and
Ethan Cohen and tells a fictional story
about real life Hollywood fixer Eddie
Mannix in the 1950s in it Josh Brolin's
Maddox is faced with his biggest
challenge yet after actor Baird Whitlock
played by George Clooney gets kidnapped
during the filming of an epic called
hail Caesar and is held for one hundred
thousand dollars Ransom the movie takes
place at a transitional time for the
film industry as the studio system was
breaking down and TV was threatening to
take away audiences the fictional Studio
seen in the movie Capital pictures
previously appeared in another period
film from the coin wins 1991's Barton
Fink speaking of the cohens they first
began discussing this idea back in 2004
they pitched the idea to Clooney in 2008
but he wasn't initially excited about
playing another numbskull character
after films like Intolerable Cruelty but
the project ultimately came together and
filming took place in the fall of 2014
in Los Angeles
so uh now do I get a share of the ransom
no
Mr Whitlock you could hardly share in
your own Ransom that would be unethical
that doesn't seem fair fellas I mean the
whole setup only works if I play along
right if I don't let on that I know who
kidnapped me yes that's right
who are they named names
if I just I tell the truth
location manager John panzarella who
also worked on 1997's LA Confidential
noted that period locations were
disappearing fast so they ended up
mostly using the Warner Brothers Studio
which would retain many of its vintage
buildings the Los Angeles Times reported
that the Coen Brothers decision to film
in Los Angeles increase filming activity
in the city which had previously been
down hail Caesar went on to receive an
Academy Award nomination for best
production design but lost to another
film on this list La La Land the critics
consensus for this one says that packed
with period detail and perfectly cast
hail Caesar finds the Coen Brothers
delivering an agreeably lightweight Love
Letter to post-war Hollywood
the artist
[Music]
and the final installment on this list
is 2011's the artist this dramedy was
directed by Michelle hazena vicious and
was done in the style of a black and
white silent film or partaki taking
place in Hollywood between 1927 and
1932. the film focuses on the
relationship between a rising young
actress and an older silent film star as
silent Cinema is fading out of relevance
a potential love affair between the two
becomes more and more complicated with
her star Rising along with the
popularity of sound in movies the artist
was shot over the course of 35 days in
the fall of 2010 taking place primarily
in Hollywood along with some downtown
theaters restaurants and houses it was
actually filmed in color and later
converted to black and white with all
the technical details like lenses
lighting and camera settings being
calibrated to match the Aesthetics of
silent films of the period for instance
because Zoom technology didn't exist at
the time there isn't a single Zoom shot
in this entire movie
foreign
[Applause]
and well whatever they did it worked
with the critics consensus calling this
one a crowd-pleasing tribute to the
magic of Silent Cinema the artist was
nominated for 10 Oscars and won five of
them including best picture best
director and best actor for Jean de
jardin making him the first french actor
Ever to win in this category this was
also the first French produced film to
win best picture and the first mainly
silent film to win since 1927's Wings
won at the first ever Academy Awards
back in 1929. okay that's it our list of
the best movies about Hollywood if that
doesn't make you yearn for the films of
yesteryear then you were totally paying
attention because it seemed like a lot
of turmoil back then right anyway what
is your favorite movie about Hollywood
we want you to let us know and thanks
for tuning in to RT Essentials I'm your
host Perry nemeroff and I've got room on
the roof of my car if anyone wants that
double decker tour bus experience I'll
give it to you for at the price
[Applause]
[Music]